good
morning millennials welcome back to the
morning toast
it is inauguration day here in america
but more importantly
it is home day and thea was here
to you know celebrate alongside me and
to let us you know get out our hump day
frustrations
on him by humping him i know it's such
it's so it's always nice when it's home
day obviously of course
but the fact that it's a short week just
continues to pay off
and surprise and delight mm-hmm and it's
just so fabulous i hope everyone is
enjoying
their short week yeah no i definitely am
even though like not to be annoying but
like it could be shorter it could be a
little shorter just like a little bit
off that friday two three days like it
could definitely be shorter let's trim
off the friday um
it is a wednesday though and the news is
just cycling about lots of bachelors we
have a lot to talk about today we have
deer toasters
we have cameron westcott interview at
the end of the episode which is just
iconic beautiful stunning and smart
she's a queen
which will also be recapping real
housewives of dallas before that um
so just like stay tuned for an adventure
stay tuned for an adventure also today's
a big day for me because i'm getting my
hair cut today
you are yeah what are you doing i'm just
doing like cut off all the split ends
like in dead ends people like comment on
my instagram telling me like my ends
look split like it's so [ __ ] rude
that's so hurtful
it's so hurtful but they're not wrong
but also it's a testament to
the type of camera you're using because
it's obviously so high quality
how are people seeing your split ends on
instagram 100
so i'm getting like a trim of all the
dead ends and then i'm also going to do
a lot of layers but you know the
decision hasn't been made yet like
convince me otherwise convince me to do
an anna de armas
no i can't i will i mean i love you do
you want a petition for any sort of
haircut for me
you know i was a really really big
champion and lobbyist of your
um bob and i wanted you to bring it back
for so many years
but i think i've actually sat on it long
enough and i'm glad you
didn't do it because i don't think it's
the right cut for you right now i think
you're
you're not there yet yeah no i'm not
there yet i will go back to the bob like
but i would love something drastic like
a shoulder length
me too like a curtain bang i don't
know that's just not my vibe whatsoever
and it looks good on mars
we'll let snitch have her moment yeah
but i i don't i don't hate the idea of
doing something
major i know so i'm i really am just
going to like
sit back i'm going to give a an idea of
what i'm looking for but also say
do what you think is best yeah no you
know i want to walk out with something
that i didn't expect which is never what
you want for my haircut
but just goes to show how bored we all
are yeah but like i have a lot of
post-traumatic stress
disorder from haircuts of you know of
lives past
and i now always go into a haircut with
like very specific instructions i don't
want to leave here crying
and i don't want to lie and say i like
it when i actually go home and cry but
me too but just like i want to look at
something different in the mirror every
day like that's how much i'm just
craving a change
you know your hair is really long you're
getting to like the mole woman phase
yeah and that's what it's time
so i'm really excited because i don't
even like really style it for the show
anymore i just like put it behind my
ears or put it in a bun
so i'm excited to have like an actual
haircut and not just hair
no that's crazy yeah so that's really
exciting
and other than that i went to the
dentist yesterday all good
all good which was really surprising
because i was having some pain but oh
and then we recorded a fabulous patreon
episode that you could check out at
patreon.com
morning toast a little q a new year new
questions new us
yes very good stuff people are asking
some good questions
oh my legs are sore i'm like i've been
finding new ways to sit on this couch
that like make my boots look cool
you know what our boots looked so cool
yesterday both of us so i am
recreating my position from yesterday
and it's really not comfortable
yeah but you know beauty is pain i know
but just like being this beautiful all
the time it's a lot of work
and it's a lot of pain and being not
only this beautiful but also a published
author in t minus six days
growth in a job the crazy beautiful life
of an instagram thirst monster now
available for pre-order at
anywhere they sell books ebooks
audiobooks and hardcover books um i read
a little excerpt on the toast yesterday
did you get any feedback it was like
maverick coming out of the woodwork
being like claudia i loved you back
a bunch of people like who i know
personally who listen to the toast
they're like who's maverick
i changed a lot of people's name in the
book just because like i did not want
those phone calls like
or text messages coming in for people um
and also it's like still like your first
love like you don't want
it's personal no and it's and i've
actually spoken about him like uh many
times on the toast and if you wanted to
you could literally find out his name
but i also really like that like on the
first page on like where it has like the
copyright information it also says
some names and identifying details have
been changed to protect the privacy
of individuals like what did i write a
thriller yeah it's thrilling
yes claudia maverick the love story um
so like i would be open to reading
another excerpt
if you were open to oh sure i need you
to choose
my coffee now that this is my first
coffee of the day here i actually don't
like have enough coffee before the show
starts so
yes i'll choose a page 31
[Music]
any reason oh and i opened to page 32.
that's a good sign that is a good sign i
don't know what the sign is but
this is chapter one you know all about
um our childhood
oh this is good okay so obviously as a
child i was like
very you know loud love to sing jackie
can attack
that would be the word so you would
think my love of performing and
captivating audiences would be
persuasive
but i made the decision early on not to
get into musical theater during high
school
even though i knew i could sing better
than half those snot-nosed kids i didn't
want to be associated with the stigma of
being a drama kid
which is ironic because if you think
about it that's exactly who i was a
dramatic kid
but i'd seen mean girls one too many
times and thought that i couldn't be
popular
while also following my passion for
singing as i learned from the fictional
halls of constant billard schools for
girls and north shore high
you couldn't be a drama geek and a
popular kid it was an antiquated view of
high school but it was what i genuinely
believed
i cared more about being well liked than
anything else at one point i did join
choir for half a second
but i dropped out immediately because it
was so lame plus i really struggled to
be a part of an ensemble choir
i was a soloist through and through so
when i didn't get the first solo
i bailed thank you claudia that's
beautiful
thank you so much available at
girlsnowjob.com but also
what you just said really goes to um
further the point that we were making
last week about high school musical high
school musical the musical the series
and how
those walls are really being broken down
and you would have really benefited that
from that as a child
a hundred percent and i like i never
like
when people always ask me like did you
do musical theater and like were you
like one of those kids and like i'm so
one of those kids
but i never did it because there was
like such like stereotypes around like
being a part of certain extracurricular
activities which is so lame and that's
why when i came to that conclusion in
the book and then i watched high school
musical the musical the series i'm like
these kids are so lucky like to go to a
high school where like you could just be
anything you want like that's iconic and
and and to have like media like popular
shows like be
encouraging that is so cool yes very
very cool
i suffered the fate of mean girls and i
knew i could not join
the drama club even though i just
wouldn't i would win a star
oh of course that is your calling even
though i didn't really agree with a lot
of their production choices like my
senior play was um
pippin male leader yeah it was but you
were in your senior play
oh no no sorry my my play the senior
year was pippin and like i was gonna go
out for it but i'm like pippin
and yes the play that uh the senior
class put on
was 13 and while i didn't and i gave
such
a stellar audition and i don't want to
disrespect like
anyone who was in the production because
i feel like maybe they listen to the
show
but like i just know that i had a better
singing voice than literally anyone
like who got any bigger parts than me
not to be rude but
um it's true i'm sorry and i didn't get
it and i just felt like
it was obviously because like i'd never
been in drama club and so like the drama
kids
ran the senior production so like why
are we gonna give this person who like
literally never
entered the theater why are we gonna
give her a role i did get a major solo
that they cut
and i threw a temper tantrum and they
did put it back in
do you want to hear a sadder story yeah
i know yours yeah so
for our senior production it was um
charlie and the chocolate factory and i
was really excited to participate and
everybody who
listens to the show knows that i cannot
carry a tune but you have so much
passion
and i have so much passion i feel like i
have so much to offer and like in an
acting role i feel like i feel like
there's a role for me
and also like being an integral part of
an ensemble cast is not all about
singing like
it's about acting and dancing and energy
yeah and i had the energy to bring and
so i prepared for my audition obviously
i sang the climb
and i sang it like as good as i possibly
could
and i got the part of violet beauregard
and i was
so excited what a role perfect for you
perfect for me like literally she hasn't
sing that much but she has a big role
and
she's got a lot to offer and then they
canceled the play
oh yeah there wasn't enough interest
there wasn't enough interest that's
really [ __ ] sad yeah yeah well my
play did make it it was 13 and i got the
role of cassandra
she was just like a chatty cheerleader
um
and i'm not gonna lie it was a wonderful
experience and it made me wish like my
whole high school experience like i had
done theater
yeah well speaking of growth no job.com
book we are recording an episode next
week that drops um launch week of the
book
with claudia and the redheads and as
part of every redheads episode if you
listen
we take questions from the listeners and
so if you guys have questions about
claudia's book or upon reading it you
have
questions about the book that you read
or you know
her journey as an author email them to
the redheadsbookclub
gmail.com cause the redheads book club
is really living in the 90s
what do you mean you take questions via
email yes we do it works lovely why
don't you take it on instagram like in
the q
a um no it's too fleeting and
in email like people actually they write
like like they're full they write
thoughtful things they talk about like
their initial thoughts on the book and
we read the whole thing oh that actually
not
like they have a substance that's funny
that's what we do at the redheads no
substitutions
yeah speaking of podcasts i'm on mood
with lauren elizabeth today just came
out
one of my favorite interviews of all
time lauren is a queen and i misspoke
yesterday my taylor striker interview
doesn't come out till next week so sorry
if you were looking for it yesterday
it's not out yet but mood with lauren
elizabeth is out today and it's
so fabulous i think love to see it also
the snatchers out today
and i'm sure she has a lot to say we
jinxed the snatcher on this show
yesterday i did i'm sorry snatcher
you don't listen um so should we just
dive in because i feel like we have lots
to do
i think the snatcher is the perfect
segue into diving into the fast side
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast
jackie what's black and white
and
and is fabulous for insurance
zebra that's a good one insurance can be
complicated and that's why the zebra was
created
when you use the zebra.com insurance
finally feels like it's in black and
white
no more confusion just honest rates and
real companies the zebra is the nation's
leading insurance comparison site for
car
and home insurance they can help you
save money today it's so easy
go to thezebra.com and answer a few
questions to compare accurate insurance
quotes for free
and don't worry the zebra protects your
personal information and make sure there
are no hidden fees
or surprises along the way the best part
you can secure your insurance from the
zebra.com or
over the phone for one of the from one
of their licensed insurance agents
how much money can you save on home and
car insurance visit the zebra.com
toast that's t-h-e-z-e-b-r-a-dot-com
toast for insurance in black and white i
gotta come up with a better joke but no
that was good that was good
okay the first story the big story of
the day the bachelorette's krill
claire crawley and dale moss break
up so dale confirmed the split shortly
after e news
exclusively reported the couple was
taking time apart however it doesn't
sound like time apart it sounds like a
breakup in its truest form yeah it's
like the article came out and he was
unhappy with it so he like literally
clarified it's more permanent yeah right
i'm not coming don't be waiting he said
i wanted to share with you all that
claire and i have decided to go our
separate ways we appreciate the love and
support we've received some
from so many people but this is the
healthiest decision for us both at this
time
we strongly believe in leading with love
and always remaining true to oneself
we only hope for the best things for one
another i mean this is so not shocking
if you've been keeping up even in just
the way that they met was so
like toxic in a lot of ways just like
the jumping to conclusions getting
engaged after literally knowing each
other for a week
and i'm honestly surprised they lasted
as long as they did but i have a feeling
they haven't been together for quite
some time
um this just is like the least
surprising thing ever
and i don't know like it kind of makes
me miss claire like even though she was
like so chaotic she was so entertaining
and like
this was even though it feels like a
waste of time because they broke up
it was an adventure it was an adventure
i'm not like obviously this is so
obvious that's what you get when you
don't trust the process and you go with
your first instinct and
you jump to conclusions but i just like
when i think about claire right now
i feel sad you know like that was her
big opportunity
she completely botched it and
inbox she wanted to prove everyone
watching it like i had to hope that she
knew
knew what she was doing and she didn't
and
i don't know what happened here but like
i don't think dale
signed on to the show to leave in a week
and like be engaged and get married for
the rest of his life i just don't think
that was like really what he wanted to
do
no no it's true like when you think
about it the odds of becoming the
bachelorette which is such a
an amazing opportunity are so slim
and the odds of getting it when you
haven't been on the franchise in like
six years are even more slim so it was
really like this gift that was dropped
into her lap
and she totally squandered it and
now it's like it's sad because it's like
a joke yeah and
she's single again when she had 25 guys
who
were i mean i want to say like who were
there for her and
wanting to get engaged to her but like
dale is one of those guys and i don't
think that's what he wanted yeah
there were people who were really
interested in her
her and on the bright side a contestant
from her season has asked her out
following their split stop this guy
spencer
oh no spencer only came on for tasha he
never met claire
oh that's weird so i hope they go out
i don't know i'm just like kind of like
as much as it is entertaining it's also
exhausting and
her journey just might not be one that
needs to be televised and i think maybe
that's the lesson here yeah no no no
that's the lesson oh no no no
no no that's the lesson here it's like
some journeys need not be televised
yeah but i hope that she goes on the
state like i just
i just want there to be like something
next for her because i just feel really
sad like she just took this big chance
she blew up the bachelorette as chris
and for nothing yeah and i feel like she
just deals with a lot personally and
this is just like
and i feel like she takes like breakups
really hard she's not the type of girl
who like goes to a club
she can't she we saw how took it when
how hard she took it when no one got up
to talk to her at the group
right and i'm thinking at the end of the
day like maybe dale just didn't show up
no i think i think he did not show up
and that's upsetting because he did
mention you know quite a few times that
he would show up he would be showing up
yeah but then he did not and that's the
worst when you're expecting someone to
show up and they just don't it's
yeah it's a flake it's so flaky yeah
one time you called me flaky like it
really affected me because i feel like
i'm like
not but like maybe i am i don't know if
that's the word i would use to describe
you
currently currently no but i think maybe
when you said it you like it might make
me into shape
yeah that's probably true it's like a
hurtful word yeah it is i think some
people would describe me as flaky too
really yeah sometimes i just don't i try
not to be flaky because i just like
don't commit to the initial plan but
the problem is when you make a
commitment and that's why i live a
commitment when i make a commitment i do
try to honor it but i just try not to
make commitments you know
when i make a commitment i try to honor
it and just like pray that the other
person cancels first there's
literally nothing better than like
really not wanting to go to do something
even if you love the person
yeah you just don't want to get out of
your bed and like just avoiding it
you're just okay i'm gonna go i'm not
gonna text them and then like an hour
before they're like
hey sorry something came up and you're
just like so happy because you're not
the flaky one and then you also don't
have to get out of bed
yeah it's an iconic moment yeah um
so claire i don't know i i just it made
me sad like
i can't i know i wish i had some words
of wisdom but
your energy like i said and have said
many times is super chaotic and i just
don't know if like we would
drive yeah well our next story is some
happy bachelor news
that i don't think we've shared yet one
ari linedike jr and lauren burnham are
pregnant with twins
oh and they are revealing the sex
do they have an instagram account for
the twins yet
oh i'm sure that they do because they're
like classic influencers like alessi
had a baby sonogram before she was born
like she didn't instagram with sonograms
yeah and her instagram is like popping
now um but they are having a boy and a
girl unless he is getting a baby brother
and a baby sister you know the more i
think about it as a mom
having twins just must be ideal i know i
used to think it wasn't but now i think
that it is
it's like so much [ __ ] work like i
watched olivia like just
the pregnancy is just so much work on
your body and it's so hard and then
nursing
and to bang it out with two doesn't seem
so bad
no it doesn't seem so bad the delivery
not ideal
but still yeah i'm really happy for them
we never really talked about ari and
lauren anymore but like but we were big
supporters of that and they
really they showed up for each other and
they continued to
and they proved everyone wrong when at
the end of the day like i feel like one
of the things i really
i don't always agree with like bachelor
nation and like their assumptions about
people
but i felt like they all really took
becca cooper inside
in the re thing which of course like ari
shouldn't have chosen the wrong girl but
he tried to write his wrong
and in the end of the day like becca
ended up being becoming the bachelorette
which
for a multitude of reasons is like way
better than being a winner like
everyone wants to be the bachelorette
winning is good too but it's not as good
as becoming a bachelorette yeah
so i feel like even though it was like a
tough situation he handled it very well
and he ended up following his heart
and literally him and lauren have like
such a beautiful life beautiful happy
full peaceful life and i feel like
they're one of the people who like
bachelor nation like owes an apology to
yeah there's a few people like that
olivia cready yes she got her apology
though
she did um who else um
me i don't know but they're like that's
just one of those things that like i
remember was so
crazy like when it was all going down it
was like literally like
the biggest scandal of our lives and
it's like now it's
so silly like yeah they're so happy yeah
they're so happy
so we're happy for them see ari was a
choice in bachelor that was like so
random but i actually ended up really
liking
yeah whereas claire is like i don't know
i just can't decide if i like lived for
claire's season i think i did like
i think i was living for the chaos it is
exciting
and honestly like even though i'm really
enjoying the season of matt james like
matt james is a little boring because
he's so nice and so lovely and is in
love with everyone and everyone's in
love with him like
while that is beautiful to watch it's
not always the most entertaining whereas
claire like you truly never know who she
was gonna yell at next
and it was iconic yeah but i do think
for the format of the show like it is
important that you
feel like championing the lead yeah
claire made that hard at times yes yes
yes that's
very true she should also set up a date
with that guy who left tasha for her
because that was a great guy
unless he's in a relationship yes yeah
he was a kid i think his name was zach
jason sure she should have trusted the
process the process would have shown her
who was true but you know what she was
so determined that even if she trusted
the process
she would have ended up with david she
might have seen something about dale she
might have like you know a different
connection might have
burned slower but prospered later like
that's how the show works
yeah i mean i don't know why they broke
up but if i had to venture a guess
it would definitely be on dale's part
like i think yeah he was like out at
restaurants like
i heard he was like seen at restaurants
like with girls even kissing them on the
lips like yeah
so yeah it was i think claire is
definitely heartbroken right now
for sure and i think dale is is
wondering how he gets to paradise
yeah or just how he gets to the next
point i think dale will probably be in
paradise because they said that they're
gonna most likely do paradise this year
well i feel like it's actually really um
conducive to coven because they don't
leave the house
yeah actually for the dates but yeah no
i
i think we'll be seeing him there yeah
okay next story little update from last
week where we let you know that army
hammer was leaving the movie shotgun
wedding
josh dumel may replace him love that for
josh jumel
any money in josh gmail's pockets just
truly makes me happy
he's a king and i absolutely adore him
and so hot after armie hammer's dm
scandal
he has it has come back to bite him josh
gmail is swooping in to offer a helping
hand the transformers actors reportedly
in early talks
to take over for army hammer and shotgun
wedding which co-stars jennifer lopez
according to deadline so it's not
confirmed yet
but i also think that josh you met like
if this is some sort of romantic comedy
i think josh email is the guy i mean
there were those years where literally
josh jamel could not make a bad movie
win a date with tad hamilton so [ __ ]
good
that other one with katherine heigl
where they get the baby and like their
friends die and they have to take care
of the baby
and they end up falling in love and
she's like a a morning show producer
oh wait i'm going i feel like you're
putting two no i'm not michael i'm not
together
no i'm not because she's a morning show
well no she's an e news host
in and knocked doctor but no that's not
it okay um
their friends die and they're like two
friends who hate each other
but they have to come together because
they leave the baby to both of them and
of course they end up falling in love
and like becoming a family yes yes also
um what's the movie called i'm gonna
find it but also
safe haven yes of course life as we know
it
yes that's the one um he's just like a
great rom-com actor and i
love him and he's so handsome like i
hope every time i talk about someone on
the show who i like like someone sends
me a message about like something bad
they did
please do not send me any messages about
josh gmail like i just want to live in a
world where he's like
a nice and respectful chivalrous man and
i know that that he is i do
yeah i know in my heart the lost husband
no i just watched that oh yeah i never
saw it it was good he was
he was great he's just so handsome like
yeah a great leading man
in a rom-com he's also in new year's eve
oh yes that was a bad one yeah but
valentine's day was good
i they're the same thing to me no one is
taylor swift and one does not so
okay next story kim kardashian and kanye
west's marriage issues will be featured
on keeping up with the kardashians i
mean it's actually crazy by the way that
we've been literally
like talking about the kardashians and
kim has not spoken out on at once like i
know
and i just wanted to take this moment to
like recognize that it's been a few
weeks of these rumors
and kim still has not said anything and
for the kimye stands like
we're in a good spot there is a beacon
of light there's like for the kimi a
sans
kim has filmed her marriage problems
with kanye for the final episodes of
keeping up page six has exclusively
learned
though page six was the one to report
that they were divorcing
yes so grain of salt a source with
knowledge of their show which is ending
after more than a decade long run and 20
seasons on e later this year
said the disintegration of kim and
kindness marriage will feature heavily
in the final storyline
as they make their exit from the reality
show i mean that's like
if they are actually headed for divorce
and like that's the final season like
sad like i want to see a final season
with like iconic iconic
chris jenner moments like i want
everyone to be drinking like i want
light and happiness and positivity
i'm so done with like my tv shows
becoming just as sad as the world around
us like
i need a place to be filled with
positivity and light and that has been
keeping up the kardashians and i don't
want to see
even if they are getting divorced
honestly i'd rather they ignore it yeah
the source said that the kardashians
intend to go out with a bang they filmed
kim discussing her marriage problems but
everybody involved is on an nda
because the finale won't air until later
in 2021.
okay i just want to say my personal
opinion considering like sources just
make [ __ ] up
my opinion is that that is not true
because i think
they would rather go into their new show
with a bang
then leave it at e where they've already
been paid and they have they don't owe
them
ratings i know but i feel like they
really um
care about the legacy of the original
show and
it's obviously about the legacy is
intact yeah all they have to do is film
another season of the same stuff that
they were filming
actually but it's a different show i
don't think that they are inclined to
give any big scoop to the last season
and at some point when they start
talking about drama that literally was
two years ago like i actually don't care
yeah i'm gonna say like maybe i'll be
wrong but
i just don't think that that makes sense
like when you're leaving your job you
don't like do the best work ever in the
last two weeks yeah but it's all topical
so i actually feel like they will
discuss it on this season and then still
go into the new show with a bang i'm
excited for the new show like
i hope it's different format in the
sense like i feel like a lot of times
when there's not a lot going on in the
kardashians lives
it's so much commercials with filled
with like filler airtime and like dumb
lunch scenes with like scott and mj like
i'm looking for more i do like their
friendship as do i
but not they're not the stars of the
show and sometimes i it has felt that
way
so i'm looking for more substantial
content from them in 2021 via hulu
yeah or 2022 whenever it is whenever it
is it'll be good
it'll be good no i'm excited for them
starting a new venture is always
exciting
and i support them no matter what i
agree
fifth and final story a little
record-breaking news oh yes morgan
wallen's
dangerous the double album debuts at
number one on the billboard 200
breaks country streaming records i
thought you were talking about olivia
rodriguez well we did talk about olivia
rodrigo
last week also but we can talk about her
too because she's literally broken every
streaming record like 13 million streams
daily debuted number one just i just
thought that's what you were referring
to
um but this is also very interesting
especially because i'm a really big
morgan wallin fan
but i haven't had the time to listen to
the album like at all i've made the time
and i haven't heard it anywhere so i'm
like
and he actually released it early
because it got leaked so it was like a
really kind of a
messy release but to still break all
those records when you
don't even have like the proper like you
do like announcement then you do press
and all this like it's so contrived
is awesome no the album is sensational
and
i think it's just like a testament to
how many morgan wallin stands there are
out there i see you guys and i'm so
i'm so glad that there's so many of us
he's ushering in like a new generation
of young country music fans a hundred
percent
he was on the cover i think it was a
billboard this week country without
borders which i thought was a
really great headline i don't get it
it's like because he transcends the
country genre like everybody loves
like doctors without borders like oh i
do love a doctor's without borders
reference seeing as how theo is truly
like um
the doctor without one border without a
single one
and he's really like the leader of all
the doctors who collectively don't have
any borders
yes and i just have to say doctors is an
amazing organization we're not making
fun of it but it's just like a little
joke here at the toast yeah that theo
doctor theodore for chairman is a doctor
without borders yeah and i think it's so
important like when i when i go to
doctors i ask them i'm like do you guys
have borders
because like i just think it's so
important um to not
i think it's an important quality yeah
yeah and that's how i now feel about my
country artists
like if you are a country artist with
borders like goodbye
goodbye goodbye so morgan rollins has
none
not one thank god none not one zero
zero zero done um i'm so happy for him
and his borderless music
yeah so he has you remember the
bookstore borders yes
that was an iconic place it was so warm
and cozy it was just like a friendly
place
but i think the issue with it was that
they had borders and that's why they
didn't succeed
you mustn't have one no you not a single
one
[Laughter]
it is integral i just i really do think
that
this is a really interesting factoid
obviously the album is really good but i
do think
album streams are suffering like in this
um
new world yeah in the climate right now
where you're not going out you're not
like you know
taken out actually i think you can go on
a boat right now but like you know where
it's not the atmosphere to just be
listening to music all the time and so i
think like the fact that so many people
have elected to stream morgan wants
album says a lot about
his future as like a major country music
artist
i couldn't agree more and if i see one
more [ __ ] tick tock of people in
australia at a club
i'm literally just going to move there i
saw them literally playing champagne
problems
in a [ __ ] club so like in a club in a
club like packed to the brim
champagne problems everyone vaccinated
happy and healthy like
i was just saying this to you earlier
like if i don't get to a club
soon like i'm she's going to burst i'm
starting to
malfunction like we're coming up on like
the one year you should find the last
club that you
last day that you went to a club like in
your camera roll i'm sure i can tell you
because you're coming up on one year
of yeah it was president's day weekend i
went on a
bender and a half in miami with margot
and
we like heard about corona virus and
like that'll go away
and it was like a messy ass weekend and
you know what no regrets
because i didn't know i would have to
literally rely on those
memories for literally 12 months maybe
more
probably more yeah i'm just saying like
and i know my fellow party girls
listening will definitely hear like
relate to this but
i'm just letting you know like if i
don't get to a club in the next six
months like
there will be consequences and that's on
facts like
and i'm sorry but that's just what's
gonna happen we'll do our best human
nature is human nature yeah you can only
keep her out of the club for so long
you know i will literally go to an empty
club like i just need to feel like the
music in your veins the music on my
veins the lights on my face like
people's hot breath everywhere like
i don't know i just if i don't get to a
club soon like there will be
consequences and that's
that's the end of that um let's dive
into our tv recap segment where we talk
about the real housewives of dallas
before we bring on cameron muscat
and that segment is brought to you by
stamps.com one thing we learned in 2020
the internet is even more awesome than
we thought
groceries online movies online doctors
online and of course go to the post
office online
with stamps.com stamps.com allows
businesses to do
all of their mailing and shipping right
from their computer no need to leave
their home or office or
home office stamps.com has saved small
businesses all over the country
thousands of hours and tons of money and
now you can too with stamps.com you get
the services of the post office and ups
right on your computer plus big
discounts on mailing and shipping rates
whether you're a small office sending
out invoices an online seller shipping
out orders or even a giant warehouse
sending thousands of packages a day
stamps.com can handle it all with ease
you use your computer to print official
u.s postage 24 7 for any letter
any package any class of mail anywhere
you want to send once your mail is ready
just schedule a pickup or drop it off
it's that simple plus like we mentioned
with these discounts with stamps.com
you get five cents off of every first
class stamp and up to 40 percent off
priority mail
and 62 off ups shipping rates is a
fraction of the cost of expensive
postage meters
it's a no-brainer saving you time and
money and make 2021 the year you stop
wasting time and going to the post
office and go to stamps.com instead
there is no risk and with our promo code
toast
you get a special offer that includes a
four-week trial plus free postage
and a digital scale no long-term
commitment is required or
contracts just go to stamps.com click on
the microphone at the top of the home
page
and type in toast that's stamps.com
promo code toast
stamps.com never go to the post office
again
love it okay real housewives of dallas
another fantastic
episode yeah i do wish more of minutes
had been allotted to the actual party
because by the time we actually got the
ladies at the party it was like 9 45.
no i know and that was upsetting there
was one
frame like one shot of all the women on
the table dancing and it literally
looked like a frat party it looks like
animal house they were like
there was also no one around them it
looked like so much fun i feel like
that's exactly what you need right now
yeah like a coveted friendly outdoor
pool party where i can dance on a table
and get sprayed with champagne and i
just want to thank
mr wescott senior thank you
for providing the grounds in which this
party was held it was so beautiful and
stunning and like just a beautiful
change of scenery
agreed and i wonder how he's going to
feel about seeing tiffany like
regurgitating
tequila into his hot tub but like why
not just in the grass
yeah um that but i just think it was so
generous of him
i agree and it's so generous of cameron
to throw that party like that is
inexpensive
it was a really nice party to throw for
a friend yeah but carrie and cam have a
really good relationship
um it was nice to see brandy back like
she definitely has a lot of energy and
she's missed when she's not around so
i was glad to have her back um it looked
like such a fun party
really i feel like um i was following
the twitter drama between cameron and
tiffany into last night's episode
and cameron i guess she like really does
not drink a lot but she was like drunk
and she was like oh my god i can't even
watch this like she just like was like a
dog with a bone like
not letting it go oh that's oh i forgot
but like that was when like harry deeper
would call her like badger
yeah that's her mo that is how she gets
when she's siding with someone
yeah but she recognized it on twitter
okay we'd love to see someone who
recognizes
their interests it was like it was
getting to be too much and her and
tiffany seemed to have like some sort of
rapprochement
on twitter last night like it wasn't
toxic and negative they were like
working together that's great yeah it
was good um the party seemed fun except
you know carrie brittingham is really
annoying like with her
i am like that too but she's like takes
it to a level that's so aggressive being
the fun police and i understand like
you want it but you don't have to worry
about these women like everyone will get
[ __ ] up
and i thought she really took it too far
when she pushed tiffany in the ball and
i couldn't believe jeffy didn't freak
out more like i would have been
so [ __ ] annoyed no me too regardless
of whether or not you can swim like to
be pushed in the pool is just such a
juvenile thing to do
in a full hair makeup and makeup like
dress
on camera like i feel like when the
cameras went down everyone like fully
went in the pool
but we're still working on a television
show like you want to look pretty you're
not going to like look like a wet
dog getting out of here that's a crazy
thing to do it was really rude
i do think carrie brittingham looks
amazing for 50 though like it's crazy
that photo shoot
like she actually looked fire yeah the
photo shoot was like a little funny oh
no the photo shoot was lame sorry it was
like qvc but i meant like her body oh
yeah she looks incredible but just
it was a little like uh it was very home
shopping network corny yeah but like
home shopping network plus nipple
plus a nipple and like ass cheek too
yeah totally
um and then uh travis
and stanford stephanie like travis is
like such a dick sometimes
and i'm surprised he hasn't seen himself
on tv and like reeled in that behavior
and sometimes it's like endearing and
funny but like sometimes it's just not
yeah but i also can appreciate someone
who like
isn't just saying stuff because cameras
are there that's you know
it's just like being their their self
yeah i just think
him and um stephanie has like a really
healthy marriage like if you're having
those conversations on
camera like and it's not toxic like it's
really
helpful conversation i agree like the
conversation that they had by they're
late just so beautiful
by their legs it was a tough
conversation to have but like
the fact that they had it on camera i
think is really healthy
and then they also did their interview
together where they're like fighting
about money and i think the fact that
they can do that on camera like
means it's not so serious i agree i
think they have such a good marriage and
i'm actually the more i think about it
i think dallas housewives like have some
of the best marriages like deandra and
jeremy i'm just
obsessed like jeremy's so hot like and
he thinks ciandra is so hot it's just
like it's such a healthy relationship
cameron and court are hysterical like
two people speaking totally different
languages
court and um stephanie i'm not court
what's his name
travis and stephanie and i also think
that brandy and brian have a good
marriage but they really went through it
on her first season i don't think he's
into filming and he was like made into a
villain and i think he wants nothing to
do with it but like likes the money and
fame that it brings for brandy but
doesn't want himself to be a part of it
which i could respect
yeah um carrie and her husband seem to
be doing better
i think he got he saw himself on tv and
he's just trying to be supportive
yeah and we don't know a lot about
tiffany's husband but i'm sure
she seems like she has a happy home life
tiffany is getting a lot of
personal air time i mean the whole
episode was her shopping for groceries
yeah no but also she probably gets as
much narrating time like at conventional
time as cameron
if not more like i feel like it's
majority tiffany and cameron
which is a lot for a first season
housewife i agree but she's super funny
and her professional looks are fire
yeah um so it's it's just like such a
good season like if you're if you're not
into housewives
um i would really recommend starting
with this it's also easy to start with
salt lake city because
there's only one season but salt lake
city is like right now to me feels like
a good reality show
i guess yeah because they haven't had a
reunion yet like it's not
it doesn't have that like housewives
feel yet but there's only one season
right that's why it's easy to get into
honestly i feel like potomac is actually
really there's only five seasons potomac
and dallas are really good places i feel
like for housewives stan like
newbies to start yeah excuse me oh my
god
um so anything else about dallas
housewives that you want to talk about
no i'm just really enjoying it it's nice
to have a franchise that you enjoy but
and the wealth is is real oc is on
tonight reunion part one and like
i know that the season was trash but i
actually sometimes think that the worse
that a season is the better the reunion
is
yes because there's like more to talk
about and there's this huge rumor going
around
right that uh bronwyn offered cocaine to
shannon's daughter
and that it comes up at the reunion
right and bronwyn actually can't respond
to a comment because like once this
rumor came out and it came out on like a
bunch of bravo blogs which isn't always
like the most accurate
news source but i think it was pretty
much um
validated someone commented on bronwyn i
guess a lot of people did and she
answered one of them being like i don't
remember it
shannon retold it to me i made amends
and then i found out from someone else
like who was there
that's really not how it went down we'll
see but
that's [ __ ] crazy crazy in my opinion
that should be grounds for firing
yeah so i'm i'm actually looking forward
to the oc reunion
and um it appears as though gina is
looking phenomenal with her
short healthy hair and if i'm going to
talk negatively about her hair
when it looks good i have to allot some
air time to talking about it positively
and it looks really really good and i'm
really happy for her
and now after a full season of oci i see
how i ended last season as a
somewhat of the gina stan by the way me
too but you just cannot deny that the
queen of oc is currently emily simpson
like you literally and then i know you
want to deny it
foreign i'm not
but you can't she has so much energy and
by the way she went on this like huge
health journey so i think at the reunion
she works she is the snatcher she's like
so funny i watched her a little bit of
her on heather mcmahon's podcast and
like
she was just like really taking charge
of like the narrative especially around
shane in their marriage because like
i kind of feel bad for her like shane is
kind of like a joke to people he's like
short i don't think anymore i think he
had a very redeeming season
he did but i just think the way like the
audience treats him like is like jokey
and i just thought she was like really
like standing up for her man and i just
loved it like i just
love her she might be one of my favorite
housewives like of all time
even though on the worst franchise with
the worst cast ever it's easy to shine
it's easy that's true that's true um do
you want to do
your toasters or do we not oh yeah no i
i just
never mind were you being rude it sounds
like you're being a little
it was it was that i thought maybe that
you had forgotten how can i forget i
have so many cards here
okay sorry i'm trying to rush me through
my emily simpson
monologue see i told you she doesn't
want me to like emily simpson
okay dear toasters our advice segment
where we offer advice to anyone who
wants it you can email us
dear toasters gmail.com we will always
read your prompt anonymously change some
names let's get started
hello ladies thank you so much for being
so stunning and smart as well as my best
friends in the queue
wait thank you for being so stunning we
are her best friends in the cube no no
thank you for being so stunning and
smarter
as well as my best we're beautiful and
smart and we're smarter
we're beautiful and smarter let me read
it again okay
thank you so much for being so stunning
and smarter as well as my best friends
in the queue
okay i think the smarter it's just like
an error i love hearing about your lives
the toast is really one of the best
parts of my day thank you so much
sorry for making fun of your grammar we
didn't anyways
to my question my fiance lives with his
roommate mark
mark has recently been bringing this
girl home from work to stay the night
this is totally fine as i stay the night
once or twice a week as well
just to get away from my parents every
so often however
he and this girl have been having sex
literally every five seconds and it's
loud
we can hear everything through the wall
she likes to yell and we can hear
everything they are saying
it's a bit much monday night they did it
about three times in the span of 24
hours and each time
we could hear them throughout the house
this has become super
sorry this becomes super problematic
especially when we are trying to get
work or school done
my poor fiance was in the middle of a
zoom meeting when they started and he
had to go outside because of the
their ear blasting humping my fiance
says this has been going on for two
weeks molly doesn't mind that his
roommate does it
but it's getting to a point where it's
almost unbearable in the middle of the
night early in the morning during a zoom
my question is how can we politely let
our friend mark know that he him and his
girlfriend are just too [ __ ] loud
when they are doing the nasty without
being so overt
the walls are thin but it's like they
know they are allowed and don't care
should i push my fiance to set some
boundaries talk to mark myself or just
let them be during their weird sex phase
that they're in
please help signed a scarred toaster for
life
that's really tough i think there's a
few things one i think that
this is like a phase of their
relationship that you know eventually it
will
um fizzle fizzle into like a less
frequent activity they will be miss
fizzle but i think that if it's
interrupting zoom calls and work in
school
you could just say you know or have your
fiance say
bro like could you just not
well during the work day because
sometimes it you can hear it and
honestly like an awkward conversation
but when boys do it it's like bro like
it's not weird
i don't think it's weird and also maybe
he has no idea that like you could
really hear so much and
and i think that would make him like
just a little self-aware and
be more conscious of that especially
conscious of what time of day it's going
down and maybe conscious of spending
some time at the girl's apartment like
why is it always on market
and his roommate right i would just say
honesty is the best policy like this is
just
something that you just have to confront
head on yeah and it's all
it's always about the delivery not the
message yeah like it's not angry
you know it's not angry it's just like
heads up like we can hear you we're in a
shared workspace like it's unprecedented
time
yeah you know no you're right in these
unprecedented times we
have to learn how to live together and
communicate and this is a prime example
of that
it's just the topic is a little
uncomfortable but you can do it pretend
it's about a different topic then yeah
you know say he's working out yeah
machine is rattling the floors
yeah i hear you're elliptical yeah so
approach it as you would
something that's not a sensitive topic
just pretend you're talking about
something else
all right next up dear jackie and
claudia long time toaster here i just
have to thank you for all of your joy
and laughter that the toast has brought
me
especially during the hard days of
quarantine my boyfriend and i have been
together for about three years and
always had a really healthy and fun
relationship
we don't live together but it's
something we've talked about in the next
year or so
over the last month my boyfriend has
talked a lot about this girl that he
works with
red that's her name through mutual
friends she met my boyfriend who
referred her to his work and basically
got her job on his team
he calls her his work wife raves about
how fun and crazy in a good way she is
a few times this laptop has been open to
their work messages on teams and they
seemed very flirty and definitely not
the way i i talked to guys at my work
i noticed that she was messaging him her
name popped up on his phone and while he
was reading the messages
he was smiling to himself but quickly
put his phone down and turned it over
i'm not a jealous or insecure person but
something about this just gives me a
weird feeling
to layer it on recently my boyfriend
opened up to me that he is feeling
disconnected and frustrated in our
relationship
and wants to spice things up in the
bedroom and it's in an attempt to feel
more connected
over the last month i felt him being
more distant as i'm the one who usually
messages him first calls and facetimes
him goes to see him etcetera
am i being crazy and thinking that
something is going on and it's weird to
have a work wise no you're not crazy
that you message and chat with outside
of work hours do i have enough of a leg
to stand on to confront my boyfriend
about this or do you think this is
normal low point for long-term couples
especially given that we aren't seeing
each other as frequently due to covet
signed a confused corporate toaster no
there is a i like to say where there is
smoke there is not always fire but this
building is a blaze
no this would really really bother me
and it's something that's difficult to
um to navigate and verbalize and it's
not something i thought about before but
this notion of a work life i'm just not
okay with
me neither unless you're both single
right and in which case
maybe get together you're my work wife
yeah i'm i'm really not here for this
and honestly because it's so
seemingly innocuous right now like
anything that you say you will sound
crazy and you'll only drive him closer
to her and you don't have
any concrete proof and like him saying
he wants to spice things up and this is
the last
things you want to hear but this is how
yeah him saying he wants to spice things
up in the bedroom it's like he's
thinking like i think he's trying not to
have an affair and so he's like let's
make the sex crazier at home
100 and part of me is like mad at him
i'm sorry to laugh like i don't know
what i would do
i'm laughing because i'm i'm
uncomfortable and like literally like i
feel free but i kind of want you to take
your power back and like break up with
him like
but he hasn't done anything wrong yet no
i know but like just like the inferences
he's making like i know what his plan is
and like i want to beat him to it no and
like him looking at his phone and
smiling like oh how dare you
like nine chill bone chilling how dare
you laugh at your phone
when i didn't send that message how
[ __ ] daryl 100
i'm so angry and you know what
i kind of like go go to your work wife
you'll be happy there
does she love you like i can no she make
the bed and tuck in the corners like i
do no
yeah i just feel like the next update is
not going to be
i would love to hear back from you
what's our advice here
run monitor the situation you know
what nerve i want to spice things up why
because you fell in love with your work
right now it's my problem
i have to put on titty tassels that
ain't right
that ain't right now i have to incur the
cost of all these new products for the
bedroom
because you fell in love with your work
wife and you can't stop smiling at your
phone
dick i hate this guy oh my god i know
but like i think this is a common thing
like
people you spend a lot of time talking
to the people that you work with say
there's someone that you
vibe with it doesn't necessarily mean
affair but
it is this like titillating
extracurricular activity what do you do
about it
that's why i'm girl's no job you know
and i married boy with no job because he
won't have a work wife because
you know what i don't allow it my house
we have a couple rules you take your
shoes off
and you don't have a work wife yeah you
know what i think i
i think that he needs a taste of his own
medicine i think you need to get a work
husband and i think you need to start
smiling at your phone
and and like saying these things that
you need to do in the bedroom that like
would never occur to him that'll be like
where are you getting these ideas yeah
that's the advice that is it a taste of
his own medicine
yeah to see how uncomfortable it feels
like to feel like second fiddle
yeah and it doesn't even have to be like
a work husband if you could just find
someone like who you really vibe with
like and just like start texting them a
lot
yeah and smiling or like literally like
i don't know get on tinder or something
just like find someone
because that's cheap like then you cross
the line that's true don't cross the
line
you just have to toe the line like he is
okay you're right you're right
um please update us like i would love to
know what this prick does next
[Laughter]
unless you guys like unless you're
overblowing it and he's a nice guy and
like you guys have happily ever after
and then i'm really happy for you
hi claudia and jackie how you darn my
pgm boyfriend of five years recently
proposed over the holiday season
muscle tove i couldn't be happier but
i'm already running into issues with my
future sister-in-law
i love my fiance's family but any time
the wedding is brought up she always has
something negative to say
she complains about how expensive a
certain bachelorette location would be
but i wasn't even planning on inviting
her
to my best friend party she has told us
that we cannot have our wedding until
september spring of 2022 as she wants to
get pregnant
and have a baby before the summer to top
it all off i will not this is not how
weddings work
by the way they don't work they don't
revolve around the groom's sister's
calendar of the group to top it all off
i will not be having her as a bridesmaid
because i just don't want her in the
wedding and my fiance agrees
saying it is completely my decision it
sounds like you have a great fiance so
focus on that
my future sister-in-law's best friend
okay so the sister-in-law's best friend
who's like family
knows i'm not having her in the bridal
party but has said that the
sister-in-law will be upset
how can i want to ask sorry how can i
want to ask her to be a bridesmaid where
she's going to
spend significantly more money than she
would just as a guest
when all she has done is make negative
comments about all the aspects of the
wedding and complains about it cunning
money constantly
i'm 100 sure i don't want her in the
wedding but i feel like i need to
incorporate her in some other way
as two married women any advice advice
on what it could do to incorporate her
into this day
so by the way because she's married the
sister-in-law you do have a little bit
of an out because
once you're married like you don't
always become a bridesmaid like you're
like a matron or something
you could say that like give her like a
fake title
those exist for like married women who
you don't want me to be bridesmaids and
i just have to say like
wedding is the one time in your life
when you can be selfish and like i just
would not give a single thought to
what this girl's feeling is on the
schedule on the money like
oh of course but i would just say that
like if you do plan on burning this
bridge which i do think like not having
her
as part of your bridal party is is a big
f you you need to be okay with like the
possible fallout
yeah and me and me not having a close
relationship with her and i don't know
how your husband's relationship is with
her but
if you're gonna do that just realize
what you're doing and i'm not saying
that you shouldn't because i think that
someone bring
that brings so much negativity to your
day it's right and you
you just got engaged and you could
already feel like the breeding ground of
negativity right but i do think giving
her this title like matron of honor or
something
you could say i like i want you to and
maybe she walks down in the
wedding procession like that's a fine
thing for her to do but then that's no
bad choice
you'll be like a matron of honor so
you'll be in my like wedding
photos but no obligation to be on the
backdrop party as i know that like the
cost is
not something that you're willing to
front yeah i
you know whenever i'm like i experienced
it a little bit with my own work i could
even like use her own words against her
and be like because i've heard all of
your concerns about an expensive
bachelorette party i wanted to make sure
that you
didn't feel obligated to come um i
experienced therefore you're not a bride
very little with my own wedding but i
when we read these these
dear toaster submissions i'm always
really really surprised at how
how much gall people have during other
people's like simchas
it's crazy like and all you have to do
it's so easy
you just show up literally like
cleveland being quiet yeah
like be quiet smile drink done yeah no
like i'm actually such a great wedding
guest even though i hate weddings
um but like i will eat all your food i
will drink all your drinks and i will
dance tonight away like i'm actually
like a great i'm worth the 200
you know whatever you need to be a good
wedding guest but like say you're a
bridesmaid for someone like i can't
imagine
saying anything like okay where are we
going feedback sweet
like it depends because there are some
girls and boys
who have like a million best friends
and have been a bridesmaids like a
million times where it's like i can
probably count on my hand besides for my
family like the people whose weddings i
will be in and have been in because i
have like very few close friends
and so like their happiness like means
so much to me because i value their
friendship but when you have like a
thousand best friends and you're like
you've got a rogue
friend that you feel obligated school
college like
you they're less meaningful yeah and so
like you're just whatever complaining
about the bachelorette party because
like you've been on a thousand this year
yeah so my advice would be to um the
single girls really hone in
on your close friends yeah it's quality
over quantity so that way
you don't have to make hard choices and
you don't have to include girls who
aren't going to
show up for you and we're going to be
negative yeah um so that's
dear toasters again you can always write
into us dear toasters at gmail.com if
you have written up into us
and we have read your uh prompt on air
please write us again let us know how it
turned out a little update we would
always appreciate
and next up we've got our interview with
cameron wescott from the real housewives
of dallas
if you're watching us on youtube the
interview is podcast only since we are
living in coveted times cameron joined
us via zoom and she is just
a queen and it's such a fun interview
she's such a great gal
yeah um so stay tuned for that and thank
you so much for listening to the morning
toast
enjoy we'll see you tomorrow bye